FACTIONS WITH ALONG KNIVES OUT
FOR HIM.
>> AND IRAN'S CHEATING ON THE
NUCLEAR DEAL.
AND WE TURN TO ISRAEL'S
AMBASSADOR TO THE UNITED STATES.
>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
>> Bret: WHEN DID ISRAEL OBTAIN
THE INFORMATION AND HA LONG HAVE
YOU HEAD IT?
>> NOT THAT LONG.
I CAN'T TELL YOU EXACTLY WHEN WE
GOT IT.
IT IS VERY NEW.
WE DIDN'T HAVE IT AND OTHER
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES DIDN'T
HAVE IT.
IT IS A HUGE COUP FOR ISRAELI
INTELLIGENCE.
AND WHY DID THEY NOT HAVE IT
YEARS AGO WHEN THEY SIGNED THE
DEAL?
>> IF PEOPLE HAD THE INFORMATION
IN 2015 THIS DEAL WOULD NOT HAVE
HAPPENED.
IT SHOWS THAT IRAN HAS A NUCLEAR
MILITARY PROGRAM AND FALSIFIED
ALL OF THE REPORTS TO AT THIS
TIME IAEA.
WHAT NETANYAHU DID, NOT PRESENT
ONLY A SMOKING GUN.
HE PRESENTED A SMOKING SCOMBOEM
ALL OF THE WORLD SHOULD TAKE
NOTICE WITH IT.
WE SHARED WITH THE U.S.
INTELLIGENCE A NUMBER OF WEEKS
AGO AND SHARING WITH THE
INTELLIGENCE AENLSS AROUND THE
WORLD.
>> Bret: THERE IS AN EFFORT TO
COROB RATE IT.
I DON'T THINK ANYONE WOULD DENY
IT IS AUTHENTIC.
>> Bret: PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
JUMPING ON A REHASH OF OLD
ALLEGATIONS AND TO 96 THE DEAL.
HOW CONVENIENT WITH THE
INTELLIGENCE REVELATIONS BY THE
BOY WHO CRIES WOLF.